ces enfants qui ont fui les combats
assiste à un spectacle improvisé dans ce
théâtre de marionnettes un théâtre qui
s'est reconverti aussi en centre
d'accueil
olivier hier
face à l'afflux de populations déplacées
le maire de cette ville de l'ouest de
l'ukraine lance un appel à l'aide
humanitaire
nous avons besoin de grandes tentes pour
que nous puissions soutenir les gens
nous avons besoin que ces tentes soit
équipé d'installations sanitaires
appropriées et que la nourriture
puissent y être cuisinés aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'un soutien que nous
n'aurions même pas pu imaginer
auparavant loin du front vive sert aussi
de base arrière à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui stocke du
matériel d'urgence
avec la guerre vive est devenu à la fois
un centre humanitaire et une zone de
transit pour les civils qui fuient en
train ou en bus vers la pologne